From the store.
Yeah.
No,
not a charity.
You're donating to the charity of the store.
Yeah.
I don't care.
That's good.
Good.
Good donation.
Yeah,
that's a,
a place is a fascinating place really.
I was gone for seven years and you know,
I've been back for four now and it's,
uh,
it is,
I love the original room.
Oh,
it's incredible.
It's the room that's got it going.
The main wildlife,
all three.
I don't,
they're all different.
The belly rooms.
Okay.
And the main room,
Eric,
by the way,
the main room performing in the main room does not bother me.
I hate the green room.
Really hate it.
Why the cocaine piano in the middle of the room and the best piano.
Yeah.
The point being is most of those people,
I don't want to see.
Oh,
hey around back there.
Yeah.
They just,
I know it was just such a negative vibe.
I think that there's a lot of comedians that play there that are a big bowl of
dead weight.
Wow.
Yeah.
But there's a lot on the names,
but by,
by,
there's a lot that are joyful and great and I dig and I like watching and my
favorite thing to do is laugh at my fellow Comedians,
but on the flip side,
some people just,
man,
they're there.
Their presence just depresses me.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I don't feel that.
Okay.
Maybe do an impression of
just mimed my,
no,
but some really I think,
yeah,
because you know the thing,
when I started in comedy,
which is 82 working through comedians,
really,
we're a group that stuck together.
You don't think that's the case now?
No.
I think that risk,
I think for the past,
I think it started changing in late nineties two thousands to where it was every
man for himself and a lot of people,
it wasn't like you're part of this fraternity.
It was like,
fuck you,
I'm going to do this.
You know?
My thing with competition is I go do your thing.
If the audience digs you more,
great.
If I'm auditioning and you're auditioning,
go beat me in the room.
I don't give a crap,
but there's such a competitiveness.
And I know that's part of why Eddie doesn't do spots because Eddie Murphy,
Eddie Murphy B.
Because when I work with them,
I would say,
why don't you go,
he'd go,
he'd say the the looks that I get and the vibe that I get from comics,
it's not pleasant.
And I go,
I know exactly what he was talking about.
That's so weird.
I have the exact opposite feeling comedy now and about,
it's a particular like the store and like the comradery of that place.
I don't,
I don't get it by the way.
I dig a lot of people there,
but the people who I dig know I dig them right and I and the other one,
so I don't take,
don't know anything.
It's not like I spent time riding that horse,
but there's lots of guys and gals that are great.
But yeah,
so plenty of them that like please step away.
I was just having a conversation about this with a friend of mine recently who
was living for a while and a place that he hated.
And he was saying that if you're in a place where everyone's negative,
you really kind of forget that people can be positive without a doubt.
Yeah.
So why should I leave the comedy store and at least half of the Times I play,
they're leaving.
They're driving home feeling like not positive.
That's so weird.
By the way.
I sometimes now arrange it.
The only set that I do at the comedy store now is I sometimes will close the
seven o'clock original room show.
Uh,
cause there's no one after me.
So if I'm five minutes long,
no one's giving you crap.
And they've already seen the whole show.
There's no it just,
and I can do that zip in,
do it and get the hell out.
I'll do a benefit in the,
in the main room or like I did.
Uh,
what did Tony Show?
Right.
Kill Tony.
Yeah.
We're gonna bring you into the fold.
Jeff Garlin bring wedding to the phone into the fold of the nice pieces fold.
By the way.
I know the Nice,
we have nice conversations with him,
but the other people are always there hovering over us.
I don't like all good.
I don't like a hover over is over.
And that is brutal when you're having a good time.
If you're not into a group,
if your group is not about making people,
uh,
like,
I don't care whether your political,
social,
w w how you do your comedy.
But if your ultimate goal isn't to bring joy into peoples lives,
what's the purpose?
If it's not about the lapse and joy.
And so I find,
here's the thing,
I don't dig Lottie ego running around the store when I'm there.
And most of the people I don't like have the biggest egos.
Do you think that the most common you because you're a very accomplished guy,
so maybe that's why you're getting that weird vibe capable.
I've been told that before,
but if I thought that that would be weird.
So I don't,
I don't know.
Maybe.
Well that's cause you know,
there's a great line,
I'm not an,
I'm not an alcoholic,
but I do know this line from the program,
which is what you think of me is none of my business,
which I love.
That's a great perspective.
Great perspective.
So what they think of me is none of my business,
I just know what they're putting out there.
That's all.
Yeah.
I think sometimes people will look at you and go,
well here's a guy who has been on some of the all time greatest television shows
ever.
You know,
you're a god that's got a massive,
like your,
your,
your resume,
your accomplishments as a comic and performers.
It's very enviable.
So maybe perhaps a set like this myself as a generous guy on every level.
I liked being generous and I like helping comics,
you know,
sticking my hand out,
doing what I can to help.
So I don't feel that I put anything that they should be fearful of out.
No,
but I think it's their own issue.
I mean,
I remember when I was,
yes,
when I was starting out,
I would get real uncomfortable when I was around really famous people.
I'd be like,
wow,
this feels weird to be around this guy in real life.
I mean I get that.
That can be,
but generally you are.
You've always been very,
very friendly.
I like to be a warm,
thoughtful person who most of the time prefers to stay at home,
go out.
If I'm gonna go to the farmer's market,
if I'm going to go to the comedy store,
I'm prepared to talk to people,
take pictures of people,
be warm to people,
engage with people.
Cause if I don't want that,
I stay home.
Right.
And so if I'm in a negative,
bad mood,
um,
I really will go do my setting,
get out.
But that doesn't happen very often,
but I'll stay home.
Yeah.
That's why you need that downtime,
right?
Yeah.
Cause you gotta you gotta be able to recharge.
Gotta be able to recharge.
And I never,
I used to not allow myself that I used to be worked so hard.
I was reading this article yesterday about Tom Cruise and about Tom Cruise's
life being very strict.
Jesus Christ.
Jeff Garland has going on with your phone.
What was that?
My brother Ringer.
What does that,
it's a theme to a man and a woman,
but a DA,
da Da da Da da Da da Da da.
Do,
do,
do.
No,
and a man and a woman is,
I thought that it's a French movie.
She's.